of course I want to thank my wife that
without her I would do nothing I mean
Kyle Richards and Maurizio umanski are
denying the rumors that they are getting
a divorce after 27 years of marriage
rumors began Monday after People
magazine reported that they've been
separated for a while but are still
living under the same roof in a joint
statement the pair addressed the rumors
saying in regards to the news it came
out about us today any claims regarding
us divorcing are untrue the couple admit
that they've had a tough year adding
that it's been the most challenging one
of our marriage but we both love and
respect each other tremendously there
has been no wrongdoing on anyone's part
they ask that their fans allowed them to
work through our issues privately adding
while it may be entertaining to
speculate please do not create false
stories to fit a further salacious
narrative after reports spread many fans
of the Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
pointed out an eerie prediction from a
medium in season one if my husband ever
leaves me I'm going with him he will
never emotionally fulfill you ever know
that
as soon as the kids are bigger you'll
have nothing in common
[Music]
Gwen Stefani and Blake Shelton are
celebrating their second wedding
anniversary
[Applause]
yes the couple shared posts on Instagram
reminiscing about the day they said I do
Shelton shared a picture of them next to
their wedding cake writing happy
anniversary Gwen Stefani every day has
been the best day since I met you and
Stefani shared a sweet video montage
captioning it happy anniversary Blake
Shelton I love you
[Music]